add-on la lumière projecteurs mesdames
et messieurs je vous demande d'applaudir
enfer
[Applaudissements]
ouais voilà papa bleus bonjour ton père
c'est le big show ça fait pas longtemps
que j'ai pris ma retraite
donc je veux être un maximum auprès de
vous toi les filles aimaient ceinture de
champion qu'est ce que t'es belle toi tu
parle de moi de la ceinture toi ok vous
deux je vous écoute
j'adore les disputes entre serbes tu
sors mon pack tempo quand elle a joué
dans un bon joueur n'avait eu d'autre
effet sega vous l'impression d'avoir à
faire
bon j'ai vu comme une absence
nous allons fixer des limites dès le
départ nous on parle de mes filles c'est
pas comme si j'étais un ex catcheur son
objectif dans la vie je suis quand même
votre père je vais vous punir
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi j'y arrive pas tu
grandis tellement envie
[Musique]
on est une famille je gère le reste je
sais pas quoi dire embrasse-moi grandes
étapes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui est censé être adulte non
j'ai parfois tendance à l'oublier
wahou
là
[Musique]
ficelez michel butor 9x beach où elle a
pâti tout ça
et ici ma maison avec toi je suis très
bien là aussi
est ce que tu vas pleurer si mais plus
tard quand je serai dans le bain